hi I'm Russell and Piazza and it's my
honor and pleasure to be talking at the
Symons Institute with dick Karp who is
just completing his five-year term as
the inaugural director of the Institute
so dick also is probably the most
influential person researcher in
theoretical computer science and one of
the most influential researchers in all
of computer science so so as I said this
is really an honor to be to talk to you
about your career oh thank you I'm not
sure I recognize myself but I'm
delighted that you came up from San
Diego to take part in this event and I
look forward to your your questions so
how did you get interested in
computation I was a failed math major I
undergraduate I took the all the courses
for the math major and when I got up to
sort of graduate level mathematics there
were people in the classes who clearly
were had a greater aptitude for it than
I did what I didn't know at the time was
that one of them was a was going to win
a Fields Medal and another one won a
Nobel Prize
Harvard was the kind of place where math
prodigies sort of popped out of the
woodwork and so I began taking courses
in the computation lab which had been
founded by Professor Howard Aiken who
created some of the first digital
computers another influence was that my
mother told me that data processing was
going to be the you know the future the
plastics of the future and I should sort
of get into it so I hope your mother
invested in the stock market no she was
very cautious she bought government
so so I began moving my interests into
the computation lab and I managed to
take all of the theoretical courses they
offered they weren't very many of them I
managed to minimize my participation in
courses that involved soldering or other
less because I knew that that was not my
apiary
and I think I realized that even though
the subject was not well developed there
was great potential and things were
happening and IBM was dominating the
computer field and it was clear that
computation was going to be incredibly
important in society and how do you
think of you know when you sort of
characterized your work to other people
what did you do how did you describe
yourself I guess I would say that I
liked discrete or finite mathematics
that I'd like to algorithms that I had a
bent for probabilistic reasoning and I
was also very influenced by the
developments in operations research
which was a budding field after its use
in world war ii and and so i took one of
my favorite courses was on computational
methods in operations research and again
the discrete nature of those models and
the fact that probability was involved
made it very comfortable from the ni I
did well enough to gain the attention of
some of the faculty and fortified my my
interest so this is somewhat of a
digression from the kind of historical
record but so there's kind of like a
wave within computer science and maybe
moving back
towards continuous mathematics so
traditionally just what you said
discrete mathematics has been thought of
as the mathematics that's involved in
computation right but there's gonna
benefit going showing a lot of
relationships between discrete
mathematics and continuous mathematics
does this seem like a step forward or a
step back well I think it's a wonderful
development I'm really thrilled by the
work over the last seven or eight years
in in spectral methods and you know the
realization that solving linear solving
special types of linear systems of
equations can be done very efficiently
and lead to improved combinatorial
algorithms I remember some years ago at
Carnegie Mellon and my friend Gary
Miller told me that the the right way to
solve Network flow problems was through
linear algebra I scoffed because I knew
very well it seemed that the best way to
solve those problems was to push flu
flow through the network of one path at
a time and I have to concede that linear
algebra methods really have won the day
also in optimization I think even though
in theoretical computer science the
emphasis has been on discrete methods
combined with linear programming and who
later sent me the semi-definite
programming
whereas in applied mathematics and
engineering there's always been the
strong activity in solving systems of
equations and minimizing functions by
continuous methods and here at the
Institute we've we're running a huge
program which brings those two schools
of thought together it's a very exciting
development so I think it's quite
enriching that these mathematical
methods that are reconverting be
converging
ya see you mentioned the flow problem
and I think that was one of the problems
you you worked on a lot both I guess
in the ER you know sort of when computer
science it was a very instrumental in
getting sort of the ground rules
established for algorithm design but
it's also like a still cutting-edge
research topic so do you think the flow
problem is is somehow special and or is
it just a historical accident it's been
played such a pivotal role well it's
such a beautiful example of some general
principles the it's a it's a special
type of linear program with extreme
points are integers so that that makes
it very special linear programming
duality and like the use of prices and
so forth really was first Illustrated
and in the context of the network flow
problem and it's a continuing theme it's
also it's it's an example of a problem
that's in NP intersect Co NP by virtue
of its formulation is a linear program
and I just my favorite algorithm is
probably the Hungarian algorithm for
solving transportation problems or
matching problems where it advances
inexorably to the solution this is the
old-fashioned way rather than the linear
algebra way by modifying a flow so it's
just a beautiful example I one of the
first books I read in operations where
research was the book by Ford and
Fulkerson on network flow problems yeah
so when I teach Network flow to two yeah
I guess either undergraduates or
graduate students I often like use it as
a precursor to NP completeness right
because in addition to being a beautif
problem and important in its own sake
it's also a problem where you have many
surprising reductions uses of network
flow to solve problems that don't seem
at all related to network flow right
you could even figure out whether a
baseball team is mathematically
eliminated use a network flow I don't
know that one
so the did do you think that looking at
the different applications of problems
like Network flow sort of put you in a
in a good mindset too yeah you know to
anticipate NP completeness when it came
along well I think there were some other
experiences that brought home to me the
possibility of combinatorial explosions
the my first assignment at IBM was to
work on algorithms for in programs for
digital circuit minimization this was
before the age of integrated circuits
and so you had these individual gates
that cost a dollar you wanted to use the
smallest number of gates to compute a
boolean function and before I arrived at
IBM the group that I was that I came to
join had already had a lot of success in
solving boolean minimization restricted
to two level circuits of answer and
zaboor the karnaugh map or well karnaugh
map was a visual aid yeah but they were
dealing with functions and many
variables and they had very successful
programs but didn't guarantee getting
the cheapest solution but could do a lot
better than the engineers could do and
so that was a big hit at IBM
so we working with my boss at IBM John
Paul Roth mathematician we started
working on multi level boolean circuits
and we soon found that it was a morass
of difficulties and we never really got
a full product out of it and the problem
was just too difficult incidentally the
project of minimizing those circuits
also was my first example in management
because I was cast as the boss of a team
of programmers and that really wasn't my
forte because I sort of left left them
alone for months at a time and that was
a contributing factor in the generate
anything useful but anyway that that
project brought home to me the seeds of
a combinatorial explosion but there were
many other signs that that was a problem
if you sort of generalize some of the
flow problems to set cover problems you
eventually if you try to generalize
matching to a sort of three-way managing
or something like that you immediately
run into problems where you don't have a
nice characterization and and the
combinatorial difficulty seemed
overwhelming and I was aware of that I
also worked on the Traveling Salesman
problem with my friend Mike held and
there again we were doing
branch-and-bound and and other basically
numerated methods and realized that I
wouldn't have been able to formulate it
very well but I realized that there was
a qualitative difference between the TSP
the Traveling Salesman problem and the
matching problem
so the so the the circuit minimization
problem trying to find the smallest
boolean circuit that computes a function
is so sort of has a very rich history so
it's also widely studied in the Soviet
Union yes the time around the same time
I believe yes and that also sort of
inspired a lot of researchers in the
Soviet Union to Startalk thinking about
this concept called para Boer right
which is kind of analogous to the
intuitive idea of combinatorial
explosion that you were talking about
that's right so but an interesting thing
is so both this is still a very
practical problem there's whole you know
a whole subfield of computer science
devoted to trying to minimize circus now
the problems become a lot more complex
because of they're a lot more they're a
lot more varied cost than just the
number of gates but still the the
process the the problem doesn't become
easier it becomes harder when you have
all these different kinds of costs and
it also has a lot of implications for
complexity mmm-hmm so it's kind of
surprising that I think this problem is
very basic but it's the one of the few
whose difficulty computational
intractability we understand least still
yeah I guess it's not obviously an NP it
depends on exactly how you formulate
exactly how its presented but in some in
some reason tations if you have a
compact input right it's not even clear
that you have short proofs about of
optimality so yeah I don't know exactly
what the complexity status of the
problem is yeah on the other hand there
are some like reasons why the problem
might not be np-complete and also some
you know things like some connections
like if you had a fast algorithm for
this problem you could actually use it
to do things like prove circuit lower
bounds to prove that other you know a
fast algorithm for this problem shows
other problems are actually limited as
far as their algorithms that sounds like
the impressive work that Ryan was has
been referring you know has been working
really Ryan definitely involved in this
yeah very remarkable connections between
circuit low amounts on the one hand so
we also brought up and we keep on
mentioning NP should maybe like I don't
know who the audience is going to be
maybe we could define our terms at some
point so NP so the lot of problems are
about searching for a solution that
meets certain specifications through a
huge space of solutions or finding the
best solution when you have some kind of
clear objective function so NP is
essentially the class of all the
problems that involve searching
optimization an np-complete means that
if you could solve that one problem you
could solve any problem of that type so
so I'm just explaining this for the not
for your benefit you certainly know this
but for the benefit of any kind of a
hypothetical P over here but so one of
your your I guess the the thing that the
paper that your still is like one of the
most cited in computer science cited not
a computer science paper that cited not
just in computer science but by
scientists of all types is is your work
on NP completeness and one thing I was
curious about is sort of the there were
like three papers that sort of brought
up this area maybe four if you include
Leonid Levin's work in the Soviet Union
yeah there was Jack Evans work on on
matchings which mentioned the problem
the
problem of P versus NP there was Steve
cooks work on showing this there existed
some natural np-complete problems and
then there was your paper showing how
prevalent np-complete problems were and
showing that a lot of the problems
people were trying to work on like
traveling salesperson were in fact
np-complete yeah so how where were you
so what brought this to your attention
dude well I was quite aware of the work
of Jack Edmonds and in the 60s he was
actually focused boron NP intersect Co
MP I think he took it as self-evident
that P was different from NP and never
actually framed exactly that question
his interest more was in what he called
the principle of the absolute supervisor
which had to do with sort of
verification of a solution and in in
modern terms would be called the
question so Jack was an absolute genius
who sort of blazed new trails in
combinatorial optimization I I think of
the first generation generation as the
people who did linear programming and
flows George dancing
Fulkerson and so on and then Jack
pioneered the next very rich development
non bipartite matching Metroid's
numerous other things and and and he
certainly stressed the importance of the
question of whether there is a
polynomial time algorithm for these
problems and he demonstrated some
wonderful polynomial time algorithms I
visited him at the National Bureau of
Standards one day probably around
1964-65 and it was pivotal in my life
because in in the eight hours I spent
with him he just told me about all of
this cornucopia of wonderful results and
and so I was certainly aware of the
the issues around polynomial time
computation and I also wasn't aware of
it at the time but I read parts of
Hartley Rogers book on complex on
computability theory which came out in
the late 60s and that sort of got me
prepared to think about reduce abilities
because he thought about you know
recursive reduce abilities and I think
that that sort of planted a seed that
led me to my work on reductions Steve
cook is a wonderful guy he was at
Berkeley for the we overlapped for two
or three years I guess I came in the
winter of 1968 and Steve was already
there and we made it Berkeley for
probably five years after no three or
four years after that and I knew about
Steve's work on arithmetic circuits and
and the like but his work on NP
completeness actually appeared he never
he and I never had a discussion of it I
think he had gone off to Toronto and so
I learned about his work by reading his
paper so you never really talked to him
directly about the time only much later
yeah we never know we never I never
talked with him directly about it at
that point but of course I read this
paper where he showed the completeness
of the sat problem and also the klique
problem was sort of in there yeah and I
sort of had a Eureka moment you know
that you know you know I've seen all
these other problems covering packing
matching and so on sequencing and I'll
bet that they're just as hard
that and so I began to systematically
pursue it and used reduce abilities I
actually used the different kind of
reduce ability than Steve had used but
that's just a technical point and the
actual once I decided to do it I I was
familiar enough with the field of
operations research that I knew what the
generic problems were their lot in being
looked at and finding the reductions was
actually not so difficult they they're
they're not there were a few that I had
trouble with I remember that I I think I
had to get a little help from Jean
Lawler and baumkuchen on the Hamiltonian
circuit problem which is somehow that
eluded me but most of the reductions
were fairly easy to find but I it was
eye-opening for me and also for many
other people that the great majority of
combinatorial search problems that we
encounter are np-complete it's it's only
the rare exceptions that are notable and
are not just this year that kind of
intuition was formalized with a proof of
the the dichotomy conjecture are you
this is I know it for counting oh oh
yeah for boolean for great satisfaction
for constraint satisfaction problems I
had a student Tom Shafer who was in at
the beginning of that he he classified
sets of boolean primitives into and and
found that yeah I'm more from I'm not
terribly familiar with that work
there's the analogous work on the
classification of counting problems
mm-hmm genius I has nice results they
basically say that all of the problems
are and split beautifully into two
classes most of them are
equally hard and the others are equally
easy yeah very nice yeah so so you
mentioned you working with some students
you actually have like a very large
number of very successful grad students
you've worked on and one thing we were
talking about earlier is that these
students have very varied careers you
know talk about brag about some of your
students oh yes I'm happy to brag about
them my my first student was a man named
Ray writer who unfortunately is deceased
and I worked with him during a leave
that I took for my BM and I should
mention that we've got my PhD at Harvard
in 59 and spent and then spent nine
years at IBM research which was a
wonderful place to work yeah and in the
middle of that I spent I took a year off
to teach at the University of Michigan I
met rewriter and he has gone on to he
went on to very important work in
artificial intelligence a field that I
really haven't worked in so my students
have done various things in networking
there's Sally Floyd and has done some of
the fundamental work on flow control in
the internet and and Phil Gibbons faith
ellen has done important work in
distributed computing know'm Nissa and
his genius he's a founder of of the
computational economics of the game game
theory and it was only nominally that I
was his advisor I learned from him but
basically the information transfer was
from him from big person to him so he
taught me a lot very little
Rajeev Motwani also unfortunately
deceased did some wonderful work on
probabilistic analysis of graph
theoretic problems for his thesis wrote
a nice book on randomized algorithms
with Rebekah Roger lon
regrettably I turned down their
invitation to be a co-author of that
book that was one of my major mistakes
in life Rajeev unfortunately died young
but he was a guru in in Silicon Valley
he he was a wonderful theoretician but
he also understood how the valley worked
and was a great adviser to let's see who
else my Clube did fundamental work on
communications Indus started a company
and is now now at Qualcomm very
successful Barbara Simon's became
president of the ACM I could go quite a
few but the the I guess like the thing
that stands out to me is how varied
their careers are oh I didn't even
mention the people who do computational
biology yeah computational biology I
never did as well at that as I would
have liked but I did influence a number
of students who did better than I did
like Dan Gus field and Ranjha mirror and
Eric seeing Dan was working in that area
before it became trendy yeah I think
that's right and I neared a lot of the
idea that would pick up in the in the
human genome project that's right that's
right he his book is on sequences and so
forth is very very notable and he it's
not a lot of important work so what was
your philosophy in advising students you
know how did you in did you
give them projects to work on no never
never I always wanted them to discover
their own problems
I mean sometimes they gave them a boost
I remember in some cases I would sort of
suggest a starting problem but basically
I wanted them to follow their own path
of discovery and they had different
personalities and and different
preferences some of them liked to do
collaborative work with others a few of
them did collaborative work with me I I
was pretty I've always been pretty lace
a fair I was sort of I made myself
available but I I really wanted them to
work things out for them for themselves
and some were extremely independent
knowingly some didn't really need an
adviser others others needed some some
guidance and I tried to be encouraging
and be available as a sounding board I
think the minute the main thing was was
was to feel out what style each of them
desired and one thing I remember you're
saying when when I was a grad student at
Berkeley not your student but a student
at the same time that you were a
professor as you said that what makes
what each researcher needs to do is find
their edge mm-hm and I interpret that as
finding something that you're
particularly good at that's kind of
synchronizes with your talents is that
what you meant exactly yeah
so in in my case I would say that part
of my edge was a
a good feel for probability theory and
not not measure theoretic probability
but good down-to-earth discrete
probability then I was able to work with
with those tools I tend to be drawn to
the finite problems that other than
infinite problems so I really like
problems where you can do examples and
one of my peculiarities is that instead
of going out and writing programs to run
an algorithm I will sit like a slave
executing the algorithm one made up
examples to just get a sort of intuitive
feel for what happens like if that gives
you like you know if you just look at
the input and output you're not you're
missed the process yeah
yeah that's right that's right in
general when you read people's papers
they don't reveal the process how they
were led to what they did that's too bad
I think good expositor should lay out
the process what I'm not good at is is
constructing very complicated proofs I
would say that I'm not the right guy to
help you check out your proof that B is
unequal to NP no one wants to be that
guy I like to work with people who are
better than I am that that's a big help
well that the challenge that you have to
find those people yeah so I've worked
with some marvelous scientists and
enjoyed that I've had wonderful postdoc
sigh but I must say having Victor
syphilis but was duck and Ravi Kanaan
and Elliott fall and been a very
enriching experience I guess I guess one
of my good qualities is that I love to
teach and and to organize material in
order to present it cogently in the
class yeah so you're very famous for
that did so do you find that you learn a
lot by doing that oh yeah I mean there's
nothing like teaching to enabled you to
master a subject you you really have to
learn the subject in order to teach it
right and I think when I first came to
Berkeley I really took my teaching very
seriously I treated each lecture as if
it were a command performance of King we
everything had to really do it right and
I would be very thoroughly prepared and
by preparing thoroughly I was able to
digress if necessary to answer a
question because I sort of knew the
territory over time I got busy with
other things
one of the aspects of an academic life
is is that you get more sort of civic
and community responsibility we have
more letters of reference to write and
so forth and so I began to compromise my
standards a little bit and so in the
later years I wasn't so perfectly
prepared and my teaching ratings dropped
a little bit I think students are
becoming much of us here too actually
one thing about the EECS Department that
I belong to it certainly the standards
of teaching are incredibly high mm-hm
and people take it very seriously I
haven't taught it's been several years
since I taught because of my duties
Symonds I haven't had the opportunity to
teach classes or the or the requirement
to teach classes and I'm not sure I
would enjoy it in the present climate
where you have to be a manager of 25 TAS
it's true I used to want to learn all my
students names yeah now I want to learn
all the TAS names by the end of the
course exactly my my colleagues seem to
adapt readily to this and to actually
enjoy it
there are positive things about anything
if you've been teaching a large
introductory course and you walk across
campus people will point at you and you
know point you out but I I don't think I
would enjoy teaching these math courses
that we're offering nowadays have you
ever written a textbook or been tempted
to write a textbook no I haven't again I
even though I was thorough in my lecture
preparation I'm fundamentally lazy
there's a certain amount of dog work in
writing a book maybe I overestimated the
the challenge of it just getting all the
names right in the index and so yeah
yeah I've never done that I've written
I've produced some pretty good lecture
notes that could have been turned into
books yes I think I have some of those
you know so you when you started
computer science was kind of like just
defining itself as a field that's right
and you mentioned like different aspects
you know different field related fields
that were kind of all contributed
there's operations research there was
recursion theory now called what
computability theory yeah and and I
guess even like Electrical and Computer
Engineering right you know Electrical
Engineering played a role
do you feel like you know were so though
then at that time people were like
coming together now I get a sense that
maybe the the field is becoming breaking
up more into specialization yes and it's
harder to communicate do you have the
same sense absolutely so they were there
there were two aspects to your comments
one is about the various influences at
the time I was a student and the other
is about how the field is branching out
currently so as a student I had never
heard the term computer science but I
was in a computation laboratory and I
took numerical analysis I took a number
of electrical engineering courses I was
terrible in the lab I could never make
anything work in the lab in fact if I
can digress for a moment some years ago
I was lucky enough to get an honorary
doctorate at the University of
Pennsylvania and the person who
introduced me at the ceremony had been
in the lab with me when I was taking the
course on all circuits and he took time
out to marvel that the idiot the klutz
who had been in this in this lab we've
already established that your edges
stopped soldering it couldn't do
anything good could ever have done
anything worthwhile so anyway I took a
number of courses on servomechanisms and
control and so on so it's quite
different than the current theories of
course and circuit circuit theory and
the courses I like most were those that
had to do with probability and
statistics I just somehow that always
resonated with me so
so if you had asked me whether I was a
computer scientist it wouldn't have done
how to answer at that time and if no one
would have asked because no one would
have asked that's true
but I had a stroke of luck and in a
landing a job at IBM I went on the
market there were no academic jobs that
I could aspire to at that point so I
interviewed at a number of companies and
IBM was by far the most appealing and I
had to choose between a few different
offers within IBM and I realized that
discrete math was what I wanted to be
doing and so I joined the switching
Theory group to as my first assignment
and there I think in some sense the
field of computer science was sort of
what IBM did so so in that sense I was
embedded you know and I think another
influenced a little bit later was Don
Knuth this work is a volume one in
particular which sort of launched the
analysis of algorithms as a as a topic I
think up until seeing Knuth work I had
been pretty naive about step counting
and that's that sort of thing some
algorithms were nice because they were
pretty and I didn't really get down to
analyzing exactly what the time bounds
were so I learned that partly from Knuth
and I followed the results in complexity
theory
Michael Rabin came to visit the IBM lab
and we had wonderful conversations we
lived in the same apartment in the upper
reaches of New York City and we drove
every day for a while to to the IBM lab
and Michael would teach me things
it was great so getting to go to IBM was
great it was a period when IBM had 75%
of the computer market and they could
afford to be lavish and just let people
do what they wanted to do rather than
work for clients or customers and there
were very good people I learned about
integer programming and learned a little
bit of linear algebra and there are
certain tools that you can you know that
it can take you a long way yeah max-flow
min-cut
linear algebra and Chernoff bounds and
you know a few oldies but goodies that
you can use over and over again so I
learned some of the tricks of the trade
that IBM I spent nine years there what
was your question again
oh so that's like you're talking about
how computer science came together with
all these different influences yeah
there was you know Electrical
Engineering and like circuit circuit
design then was circuit theory was part
of Electrical Engineering I suppose and
then there was people like Michael Rabin
who were coming from computability
congrat city yeah and and then Donald
Knuth was sort of like established the
rule book yeah
wrote the book were little early that
sort of like said what what are we doing
in designing algorithms right so that's
sort of like saying how the field came
together don't sing with let's go
forward like a number of years and say
do you feel like the the field is still
cohesive or is it maybe becoming very
specialized are we about to maybe see
the birth of other areas sort of
emerging from recon recombining
different aspects of existing fields
right well that's definitely happening
so for for a while
one could use a very modest toolkit of
techniques and make some progress on
interesting computer science problems
and the these often were problems that
had a sort of real world relevance and
there were just a lot of things to be to
be done and basic algorithms but as the
field has developed I used to I used to
compare what we were doing in the
computer science to 19th century
mathematics that it was still pretty
intuitive that you know that you could
really understand something about all of
mathematics and and of course the
frontiers of mathematics moved way out
so that people in one specialty really
have trouble communicating with other
specialists right different parts of
mathematics maybe cows what's the last
one
understood at all maybe yeah but you
could you could follow a little quite a
bit of it but now different specialties
in theoretical computer science have
become very advanced and and the
frontiers are pretty far out so you
can't just jump into let's say security
and privacy or for cryptography and and
expect to to contribute without knowing
quite a bit of lore or in every area
whether it's Elda computational
algebraic geometry or spectral analysis
or or computational logic the the field
has moved pretty far out and I think in
a sense if you think of it as a growing
tree it's gotten to some extent
separated from its roots in practicality
so I think that many of the people who
in past times would have become research
mathematicians and now using very
advanced mathematical techniques in the
context of computer science yeah and and
and there's and they're solving very
hard problems but problems that have
been refined to the point that their
connection to the practical roots of
computation are somewhat lost in many
cases and people don't really care that
much about losing those connections
because the fields sort of generate
their own identity and their own style
their own open questions you also asked
about new fields arise and of course
this is also true the data sciences data
science big data artificial and
artificial intelligence machine learning
right I mean these these have blossomed
in the last 15 - 15 years probably you
know and especially in the last just in
the very recent past yeah but maybe this
is also like an opportunity because I
think you know so not that I'm an expert
on these things but you know UCSD where
I'm a faculty member is starting a data
science major and one question work
continually so asking or mainly them
continuously discussing with Mohan for
Turkey is what exactly is data science
and you know what is the scope of data
science what makes something data
science yeah and so I think it may be in
the same stage as computer science was
in the 50s where where there was
obviously something happening but it
wasn't clear what the scope of you know
how that would emerge right but it's
it's moving along at a furious rate so
you know Berkeley and other places are
adopting the philosophy that every
undergraduate should be exposed to
whatever it is and but it if I think
maybe the can maybe the Knuth hasn't
come along to set up the ground rules
yeah yeah that's a good way to put it I
think it's not so much what it is
because what it is is really the
generation of data and the of large
bodies of data and they and the creation
of insight from analyzing that data so
that's what it is it's it's it's the
driven by the the influence of the act
the availability of large data sets in
almost any field you can name what's
less clear is what the foundations are
and what the mathematical foundations
are yeah and it has something to do with
sparsa fication and dimension reduction
and all the techniques were for
simplifying large datasets to extract
the essence it has a lot to do with
real-time decision making certainly has
a lot to do with advanced statistical
methods it's sort of the extension of
classical statistics to the case where
you have really large datasets it's the
size of the data set I mean it's the
classical statistics if you have like
large data sets that are sampled from
the same distribution
yeah it should be really good at the hat
right I think maybe the the problem is
that you have large data sets in your
with kind of uncertain provenance
exactly exactly the diversity of the
data the combining of different types of
data you know the fact that the data may
have been gathered in a way that made it
not representative
it's not clear what population you're
sampling from yeah and the fact that
there's so much data means that there's
an abundance of possible hypotheses some
of which will just accidentally seem to
be significant yeah so it's it's kind of
closeted istic son steroids and the
problems are very hard and we don't
really you don't really know exactly
where it's going yeah there's a related
field of artificial intelligence where I
mean if you read the billboards as you
drive out to San Francisco Airport
you'll see that there are companies that
are offering artificial intelligence to
the world and hiring at inflated
salaries hiring people to do artificial
intelligence and it's as if artificial
intelligence is some magic potion right
a few yes a few high priests possess it
and and if you can hire one of those
high priests that person will be able to
sprinkle his national intelligence
knowledge over all the problems in the
world right so there's some exaggerated
respect for what it is what it really is
there's been definite success in solving
certain kinds of classification problems
but first of all it's a far cry from
what the founders of artificial
intelligence meant by the subject and
you know so the ironic thing is that if
you go back 20 years ago even I think
artificial intelligence had done a huge
a bad reputation for being impractical
yeah that's right and you know an
undeserved undeservedly bad reputation
at that time so the pendulum swings
quite a bit quite quickly Wright and
dilemma for people who are used to
analyzing algorithms because the success
of some of the deep learning algorithms
has gone far beyond what we can what we
can analyze you know in fact that sort
of touches on another theme which is
empirical there empirical validation of
algorithms which is becoming more more
prevalent I think in a lot of areas so
we've seen success in sort of boolean
minimization and Sat solvers have been
successful beyond what we can explain
you've worked in feeling also failing to
explain along with everyone else
so there's been very striking work by
Kevin Leighton Brown for example where
he has been able to classify different
types of satisfiability instances and
predict which algorithms would work well
on which of those right very impressive
but completely empirical yeah but some
sense you mention work with withheld
earlier
yeah and I think was in some of your
work with him motivated by some of the
same questions like the health carp
found using that to empirically validate
an approximation algorithms oh yeah I've
always been interested in doing that and
my current work is is along those lines
yeah we could never prove anything about
much about our traveling salesman
algorithm or the quality of the I guess
the they're still open questions about
the so-called healthcare bound
there's even current work on the
asymmetric version of that the bound as
it applies to asymmetric TSP is this and
beautiful recent work but I don't I
don't shrink from experimentally
investigating algorithms if I can move
it find somebody to write the code is
staying like more ground down to earth
being able to look at concrete instances
of problems part of the reason why you
moved into computational biology a while
back yeah back about around the turn of
the 20th century the human I guess
maybe around 1995 the human genome
project was bubbling up and its
importance and my colleague Jean Lawler
was working on related problems and my
former student and Gus field had was
pioneering that subject and I sort of I
think it was sort of a machismo thing I
sort of said to myself gee if they can
do that do that I I can do it too there
are all these combinatorial problems and
I'll just sort of barge in and see what
I can do and it turns out that it's not
so easy
you're the theoretical statements if any
that you can make about your algorithms
for analyzing DNA sequences or protein
protein interactions or regulatory
networks it all depends on how much
insight you can give to the biologist
and whether you can get the intention
the attention of a biologist a lot of it
is just being in the right place to to
to assist major projects popularizing
your work writing code that people can
easily use and frankly I haven't
succeeded to the extent that I would
have liked in that area so I can't I
can't say that I've influenced the been
a big influence on the course of
computational biology except that I've
had a number of students who have really
done well Eric Shing Runge Amir but it's
a it's a tricky business and nowadays
you really have to work with a
particular project on particular data
sets in the early days the late 90s up
through maybe 2005 you could sort of
work on generic problems that made sense
sequence alignments who are phylogeny
and and so on but more and more the good
work is being done in in very concrete
context with very particular datasets to
try and understand particular diseases
or particular mechanisms within the cell
and you you really have to get down and
dirty so to speak and I haven't been
paying my dues by trying to do that so
it's like if you sort of we're you know
in the 90s people were looking at
particular see you know didn't DNA
sequences trying to unravel them figure
out what the sequences were yeah now the
goal is to find out what the purpose of
the these these genes are how they
interact with all the other proteins in
the cell right that's a much more
complex and less defined problem
yeah it's much more difficult I mean
there there are a few particular
branches where the problem formulations
are clean enough that one can continue
to do through ethic work and ewar now
for example as in phylogeny analysis and
and sequence alignment that she's
continued to find new applications new
directions and the problems are fairly
clean when you get down to looking at
proteins in particular it gets harder
they have a three-dimensional structure
you have the combinatorics of how the
proteins interact the data is not very
clean there are a lot of impediments
generally to understanding to do what
you might call cell biology meaning the
investigation of of the control
mechanisms within living cells is just a
messy subject do you have any this kind
of brings up the general question of you
know so traditional theory we sort of
like expect people to bring the problem
formulations to us but al are part of
making algorithms that actually solve
problems that people want to have solved
is coming up with the right formulation
so do you have any insight into how you
come up with the right formulation of
problems I'm asking you a tough one
that's f1 I would say that again it's
it's a matter of getting down in the
weeds like if you if you want to solve
problems for of the type that arise in
the Amazon or lyft or uber or Google
whether it's advertising or routing of
vehicles or distribution of goods you
probably have to sit down and see what's
going on and you know write it right
around with the truck drivers and see
what's actually happening yeah and again
it takes a certain dedication you know
also a lot of you know there's this this
kind of legal issue a lot of the data
for the the applications you're talking
about just now are you know proprietary
you cannot just get that information
yeah
and start working on it without having
some kind of relationship with the
company yeah there are still some some
classic problems of of complexity that
can that are very clean and can be
pursued I think that you've done some
you've sort of injected new life into a
complexity theory by talking about the
strong strong exponential time
hypothesis and where you make a very
concrete assumption about the difficulty
of the satisfiability problem and then
you take that as a hypothesis and and
find out that it implies all kinds of
results about other problems lower down
in complexity yeah that's really neat
discovery again you know so it sort of
has the same court coming maybe of some
of the work on NP completeness which he
talks about the worst case complexity of
the problem yeah or you can even talk
about the average case complexity of the
problem but talking about the typical
case complexity of the problem where
typical beans something that people
actually want to solve yeah as opposed
to a random instance or a worst case if
that's right it's so much harder it's so
much harder and
and and that's something that we really
need to cope with I think that the work
on approximation algorithms where you
get guaranteed a polynomial time
algorithms for np-hard problems that are
guaranteed to come within a certain
ratio of optimum is beautiful work which
uses very nice techniques from
mathematical programming and so on but
it really misses the mark in terms of
relevance in my opinion because the
bounds that you can prove when you're
talking about an algorithm that always
gives a good approximation so much worse
than what you can actually achieve with
those problems empirically and so even
though I admire that line of research I
think somebody has to come along and
figure out an approach that would have
more bearing on as you say the typical
instances so I want to say that
sometimes you know sometimes you really
care about getting the the right answer
to 1% right and sometimes you just care
about getting in the right ballpark
that's true and so what is a lot of
times you're using an approximation
algorithm that's kind of a meta
algorithm to help steer an another
algorithm and so the cost and being off
is like a small factor in the running
time of your other algorithm or you
mentioned like the circuit design
problem that was successful well I think
that that a lot of those the two-level
circuit design you're using like a set
cover myristic and so it can be off by a
factor of n but when you're talking
about an exponential sized circuit and
it's not so bad yeah that's possible
there's also the complexity theoretic
work of showing that it's hard to
to even get polynomial time algorithms
within any any closest factor the Bobby
I'm and I admire that work very much and
they've been some real breakthroughs
there yeah
and that it's also like one of the
bringing us back to this the idea of the
synthesis between discrete and
continuous mathematics because they're
they sort of show that the best
approximation algorithm which is kind of
an a discrete concept can actually be
like formulated as the best semi
definite relaxation right and that's a
more continuous version right those you
get these kind of very interesting you
know strange approximation ratios that
are the best achievable under possible
assumptions right that's a brilliant
piece of work involving yeah showing the
semi definite programming is in some
sense the canonical way to tackle those
problems what are some of your other
favorite developments and in computer
science well we've already touched on
some of them I I've been very impressed
with the the spectral graph analysis and
all of the things that you can do with
linear algebra spectral computation I I
think the the reductions from from the
strongest exponential time hypothesis to
prove various concrete results about the
about real real-life problems are very
very relevant very interesting some some
of my results have been superseded by
better results obtained recently so
there's some very nice work using
discrepancy theory which gets a bit of
bound for the
Caracara and i were able to obtain for
the impacting problem and I was happy to
see that the linear programming
formulation for the asymmetric TSP that
I worked on with Michael held was the
starting point for some new exciting
results about solving the asymmetric TSP
within a constant factor however and
another aspect of current day complexity
theory is that we're sometimes getting
results that depart pretty far from
anything that anybody would use in
practice so I mean the practical
solution of the TSP is quite a different
game there are there are also what
Richard Lipton has called galactic
algorithms algorithms that are very good
asymptotically but not be but not useful
within any practical range that okay I
should say like when I was in grad
school people said that the Strasse and
matrix multiply algorithm was one of the
hosts and yet I believe you know so you
know one reason why people thought that
this these algorithms won't be useful
for for input sizes that are practical
is that emphasizes that are practical
are so much bigger now right than they
were 20 years ago 30 years ago right so
so maybe at some time in the future the
rubric of Winograd at all matrix
multiplication will also be practical
exactly yeah there was one other thing I
wanted to talk about but now I'm I'm
forgetting it oh so when
you were starting research in you know
the in the field that eventually became
computer science did you imagine
computer science as being at all like it
is today and you know what ways is it
surprising to you and what ways would
you did you like anticipate well the no
there's a whole world of computation and
digital communication that we've
constructed which sort of lives side by
side with the physical world and the
laws governing this world of computation
are relevant to everyone everybody
spends time with digital devices and
benefiting from what you what you can do
with them I certainly didn't anticipate
that I mean nobody did when I was a
graduate student I mean Thomas Watson
senior said that there wouldn't be any
need for more than five computers in the
world now you have five in your office
probably five in your pocket five in
your pocket now that's no I have no no
conception my mother had told me that
they the process is important but I have
no sense of how what a sweeping effect
that was going to have on society so so
that that comes as a complete surprise
and of course there's a lot to worry
about too just as one example people
don't read deeply anymore they have so
many sources of information that they
sort of skim everything and
the art of deep reading or certainly
poetry and fields like that are no
longer no longer have the the stature
and the and the provenance that they
have had in the past and I think that's
I think we become shallow or but more
facile we're producing a generation of
people who could be great you have
traffic controllers because they can
multitask and respond quickly to the
digital stimuli and so under there's
something lost as well so I of course
nobody anticipated all of that in terms
of theoretical computer science it's
been brought home to me at the Simons
Institute where we cast our attention on
different themes every semester and
bring together the experts and in those
thematic areas
every semester I find myself behind the
curve because you know the
cryptographers come in and they know all
about the latest developments and
computing in the cloud and so on and
it's all new to me and then the next
semester it's mechanisms as a design and
economics and a new bunch of experts
come in and I'm constantly behind the
curve and discovering that the frontiers
have gone out very far and this is of
course wonderful what did you know so
like a new grad student is in the same
situation right in some sense they're
like 40 years behind yeah so what advice
would you give to a grad student
starting out and how to not be
intimidated that's a tough question no I
would suggest not losing contact with
the real world of applications and not
not simply jumping into some body of
theory
that because it's there but but actually
thinking about what my my we've
accomplished what might matter what
might lead to an accomplishment in the
world it's probably good to have a
secondary interest besides theory but
you know we've seen many generations of
graduate students coming through and
thriving and it continues Berkeley is
one of the places that keeps producing
fantastic graduates so somehow they're
managing I think being open to working
with other people being jealous of your
results but you know being out there and
collaborating is very important for
students learn a lot of mathematics one
of my regrets is that there are certain
branches of mathematics where I'm fairly
ignorant and that could have been
relevant for me taking more math instead
of those engineering courses that I took
if I had known so often like students
say what area of mathematics should I
learn to do computer science and I think
my answer is well look at all the areas
that have been applied successfully to
computer science and learn something
else something else like maybe maybe
maybe topology you're gonna come to
before right I already know some
applications of topology so yeah string
buggers but it but it's relatively it's
relatively untapped right so because I
think one one way of getting an edge is
to know something that other people
don't
that's true and you don't know what's
relevant into you know if you don't know
an area you don't know whether or not is
relevant right that's why I like this
this optimization program that we're
running at Simon's because I think it's
bringing people together with their
and we'll learn from one another with
very different skills yeah how was your
experience what what do you you know
what it you think of the role of the
Simons Institute in theoretical computer
science today and what was your
experience as director it's been
successful far beyond my my dreams and
that's the work of many many people on
earth on our staff and the other
scientists who've been in the leadership
team of the Simons Institute it's really
become the place where people want to go
to gather and and advance the field I
think it's bringing collaborative
research to a different level for for me
it's been mixed because I somehow
discovered that I'm not meant to be a
manager exactly they'll be enough
skilful colleagues to cover my
deficiencies so it hasn't gone too badly
now I'm yearning to get back and really
focus on research with your upcoming
project or do you have it
well I've been working on a certain
problem called the group Steiner problem
it's one of the classical np-hard
problems and I've got some ideas about
algorithms which I have tested partly
through computing programs and partly
from doing lots of little examples and I
think I might have some good ideas there
and I'd like to pursue that I'll
continue to be interested in
bioinformatics I'll continue to be
interested in foundations of data
science I'm told that you're going to be
on the other side as a program organizer
for an upcoming program yes yes this
began a few years ago when I heard a
talk by an astronomer named Joshua bloom
who was also very skilled in computer
science and machine learning and he
talked about robotic astronomy he talked
about the fact that astronomers don't
really point the telescope anymore they
tell us the directions that the
telescope takes the areas of the sky
that are chosen for examination are
chosen by algorithms and these
algorithms have to take into account
massive amounts of data that they that
the telescopes are generating and decide
in real time which of the many images
they've taken to throw away which ones
to keep and analyze and how to use the
results of that analysis to decide
what's likely to be interesting and
where to look next Wow so that's an
example of a problem where massive
amounts of data are being gathered the
data some of the data has to be
discarded and other has to be other
parts of it have to be analyzed deeply
and there's a a feedback loop where the
results of the analysis of the data
affect the next decisions in which data
is going to be derived that's also like
a challenge to traditional statistics in
that you're the way you're gathering the
data is an independent of the data
mm-hmm so trying to reach conclusions
you have to worry about sort of I guess
this like biased towards your your
confirming your own hypotheses yeah I
hadn't explicitly thought about that but
that is an important complication
so it turns out that there are many
other areas where a similar feedback
between rapid decision making an action
occur it's in managing the energy grid
and certain aspects of managing urban
transportation in making a quick
response to emergencies such as
earthquakes just a lot of different
application areas which in terms of
their domains of application are very
different from one another another
example is the Large Hadron Collider at
Geneva where nuclear collisions are
being observed and processed but also
like even like self-driving vehicles
self-driving vehicles
yeah it's closely related to control
theory and yeah and the like and so this
this program that's coming up in the
spring will bring together domain
scientists in those various domains
astronomers earthquake seismologists etc
with people who will be using statistics
and mathematical modeling and control
theory and streaming and real-time
analysis to try to study this
decision-making process so it's a it's a
rich stew of different topics but
somewhat somewhat diffuse compared to
the usual rather focused program at
Simons so it's not clear it's clear that
we're gonna have a lot of fun and
there'll be a lot of interesting topics
discussed whether some Universal
methodologies are derived is an open
question you know if you're looking at
the areas as distinct as robotic
astronomy on the
and scheduling traffic lights on the
other hand you know it's unclear whether
the intersection of all those areas has
something substantial but we'll explore
it there's also like the social issue
you know a lot of the Simons programs
have the theme of bringing together
researchers from different communities
but once you're there there's you have
to fight the inertia people working with
people they already are kind of familiar
with using language they're already
familiar with yeah we'll have to deal
with that of course it goes without
saying that we owe it all to the wisdom
of Jim and Marilyn Simon's in seeing
something worthy and what we were trying
to do here and making a very substantial
investment and and being encouraging
them all along with saying nice things
to us about how we're doing and and
showing continued interest and it's
wonderful to see such a philanthropic
attitude from people in the real world
who understand the value of fundamental
science I just want to say that I I love
the Simons Institute it's been the
privilege of my life to be in a position
to help with help the team to make it
work and I'm very gratified that it
seems to be working out so well
you